this is Q block a brand new modular
system for a power strip now obviously
this packaging is not the final one
because this product is on Kickstarter
as you guys could see I have a bunch of
unique accessories for this power strip
now this is something that I've been
thinking about for a long time where you
have a power strip and instead of just
having the same old plugs that are in
there well you can actually swap them
out so I'm going to show you guys how
this thing works all of the features the
specifications and these different
accessories and we're also going to test
that out the first part of it let's get
this thing out of the packaging we have
our manual with a bunch of information
and full specs which we'll cover in just
a bit and we have the Q block itself now
as far as first impressions this thing
is very solidly built in this cable
right here it is is serious this is very
thick now that's probably because this
thing can be modular in output not only
different connections but with that you
also have different Outlet plugs for
other countries as well so as you guys
could see we have two of them right over
here now on the end of this I do have a
US plug but they have other versions for
other locations now on the actual unit
itself right next to the power cable we
do have a reset switch and that is
because this thing has a surge protector
built in that will protect your
electronics and on the side here we have
these buttons that will unlock the
modular cubes here and let's test out
how strong this is when you don't press
it like if you tug on it will it come
out and oh my goodness
that is crazy strong right so it's
definitely solid now let's press down on
the button bam nice and easy so I just
pulled off this one and we'll test out
the power on that now before I get into
the other units here you guys see how
the connection is made and how it locks
and then on the bottom here no matter
which way you place it we have these
channels
um that these little blocks lock in so
this plug was set up this way right here
but the cool thing is you can actually
rotate it and lock it in this direction
or you can lock it in the regular one
and there is a little indicator which
way you can lock it in so that is really
nice because with a lot of these
accessories for example this power brick
this way is perfect because it stands
out of the way but some of them they go
horizontal instead or they could be
centered or very high so with this kind
of scenario you can actually optimize it
do you want it out of the way here or do
you want it this way and because of that
it kind of saves space and you can have
the perfect layout now to make that
happen we have these three prongs so
it's different from your standard outlet
and that is what allows it to go
different directions and then still have
the correct polarity with these channels
now here we have our standard outlet and
I have a few of these but like I showed
you guys we have some Outlets from some
other countries as well now this is
super nice because I do have some
accessories that do have
um different connections so this one for
example I have to go and find an adapter
to be able to use here and that thing is
Big it's multiple devices so here you
don't have to have something that is
specific for one country you can have a
few of the ones you need and then a
different one and so here bam let me
plug that in it's kind of in the way
here let's go ahead and unplug it
bam plugged it in this way now it's not
in the way and then as you guys could
see we also have some different colors
so they do have some different color
options that you can check out on their
Kickstarter by the way the link is down
in the description so here we have a
couple other options for different kinds
of plugs now they also have some unique
ones first off they also have these caps
that could protect the prongs if you're
going to be storing some of your blocks
that you're not using and then here I
have this guy right here now this is
actually a light with a sensor and touch
control so let's go ahead and plug that
in we're going to test that out in just
a bit let's unplug this one here and
here we have again powered USBC and USB
type 8 Port now this thing is heavy it
is very solid let's go ahead and plug
that in we're also going to test that
out and then let's remove this one right
here and I will replace that with this
guy this is a Bluetooth speaker that is
also a plug now this is where this kind
of a modular system gets very
interesting because they're going to be
a whole unlimited amount of different
kind of blocks that you can optimize for
now of course this is a small speaker
we'll test it out but in the future
they're going to be a ton of different
options now one thing I would like to
see is an Apple Watch charger imagine
you should have a power strip you can
set it down there without taking up
extra space maybe another kind of
wireless charger maybe something with a
smart assistant built in the options are
pretty much endless now qblocks also
showed me this travel bag of Cubes that
will also be available and you can see
some new designs in there so I went
ahead and plugged this in let's go ahead
and turn on the switch and as you guys
can see this light is already on now
it's shut off and on the front here we
have that sensor you can tap on the top
there and then it gets bright brighter
and even brighter and that just adds a
little bit of ambient some light where
your power switch is so you can see
things and the cool thing is if I go
ahead and shut off these lights
it will actually turn on automatically
right there like you guys saw adding a
little bit of Ambience and that is on
the lowest setting so if you want it
brighter you can also change that and
now let's test out the Gan powered
um USB module I'm going to go ahead and
plug in the Samsung phone here you guys
can see we have two hours until it is
charged and it is low so we are getting
a decent amount of output we'll check
the manual there for the full specs and
let's check out the USB type c output
because I'm pretty sure it's going to be
more powerful
go ahead and plug that in bam right
there it says we are fast charging an
hour and 22 minutes to get to a full
charge and now let's test out this
speaker I'm going to go ahead and hold
down on the button okay right there we
have that pairing chime and Bam we are
connected here
let's set that to about halfway let's
play the max Tech classic here
[Music]
so it's not crazy loud it is a very
small speaker the midterm not bad not a
lot of Base but once again you guys see
the size of this so uh it is gonna be
useful for maybe pairing it to something
for notifications or something that you
don't want to be allowed but it is a
cool little accessory to be able to have
in that just plugs in now uh the other
ones are also very cool and I'm excited
for future ones now I'm going to pull
that back and I want to take a look at a
little bit more info inside of here so
you guys could see that that USB brick
is a 45 watt Gan now that's going to be
the combined amount and it also supports
Quick Charge 3.0 and PD 3.0 as well for
that type c Port this page just shows
you the basic design and things that we
already covered let's step over here
just how you want to use it also base
things this page gives us a little bit
more info especially on the Gan charger
so it is a 45 watt charger you have a
lot of voltages that it can run which is
nice because it will support more
devices 18 Watts on the USB type A which
is standard and then if you're using it
combined that power does drop some more
info on the sensor lamp and then here we
have some info on the cubes and the
different type of plug connections along
with their voltage so you see we have
125 and up to 250 and the different
amounts of amps that that can output and
along with that it is made in Taiwan so
there you guys go this is the Q block
modular system I have those four plugged
in I have these other ones right over
here you guys let me know what kind of
different cubes you would be interested
in and then what you think of this type
of a modular setup where you're not just
stuck with just standard plugs and
having a bunch of power adapters
sticking out of there but you can
actually customize it to have whatever
you need once again the kickstarter page
is open right now we have it down in the
description below so you guys can go and
check that out click that Circle above
to subscribe check out one of those
great videos right over there this has
been Max and I'll see you in the next
one
foreign